we've recently discussed the four Titan
brothers who have personified as the
four pillars of the earth because of the
role they played during Uranus's
castration today we take a look at the
Titan Hyperion who was regarded as the
pillar of the east and the God of
heavenly light Hyperion is one of the
first generation of titans born from
Gaia and Uranus and along with his wife
Thea
he was commonly known as lady of the
aether the shine in blue within the sky
they were both heavily associated with
the heavens and the light source it
provided the earth
Hyperion's name itself can be roughly
translated to watch her from above or he
who goes from above and he was thought
to represent watchfulness wisdom and
light it's quite a common sentiment in
mythology as well as religion that the
gods watched us mortals from the heavens
above it's not much of a surprise that
the children of Hyperion and Thea were
also closely linked to the heavens in
the sky Helios the Titan of the Sun
Selene the Titan goddess of the moon and
yaws the Titan goddess of dawn over the
years there has been some ambiguity
between Hyperion and his connection to
the Sun when we think of a heavenly
light source it's natural for us to
assume that that could only refer to the
Sun or the moon and in some of the early
texts such as Homer's Iliad and the
Odyssey the Sun was referred to as
Helios Hyperion almost implying that
Hyperion could in fact be the Sun in the
later texts of Hesiod's Theogony the Sun
was referred to as Hyperion Hades
meaning the Sun of Hyperion this could
refer to the Sun being a creation of
Hyperion or it could indeed refer to
Helios but what does Theogony does is
separate the Sun from Hyperion they
described as two separate things
Hyperion being shown as his own physical
being in the text that subsequently
followed there was always a clear
distinction made between Hyperion and
his son Hyperion was often associated
with the characteristics of wisdom and
light and ultimately known as the god of
watchfulness Helios on the other hand
was often seen as the physical
incarnation of the Sun
Hyperion is another Titan that doesn't
really feature much in Greek mythology
and during the war between the Titans
and Olympians he is hardly mentioned at
all we can only assume that he was
amongst the Titans imprisoned by Zeus in
Tartarus there are those who believe
that Hyperion been a deity of the
heavens meant that he was able to
observe far more than the other Titans
and gods and because of his diligent
observation he was the first to truly
understand the movements of the Sun and
the moon as well as the stars in the
seasons it's believed that it was
Hyperion who ordered the cycles of the
Sun the moon and the dome given time and
organized structure and helping us
create our own concept of the different
times within a day also allowed us to
track the times of the month in the year
during the creation of man it's believed
that the Titans each bestowed man with
one of their own qualities Hyperion in
his wife Thea being deities of light in
the sky gave man the gift of sight
although Hyperion doesn't play a huge
role in the stories of Greek mythology
he was quite an important figure
nonetheless not only because he was one
of the first forms of light when the
world was created from chaos but because
his observations meant that he created
the cycles of night and day he's
children the dawn the Sun and the moon
symbolize in the different periods of
the day itself he also gave the ancient
Greeks a way to measure the seasons with
these different cycles during the year
something that would be extremely valued
by farmers and anyone whose livelihood
was dependent on the weather in the time
of year
Hyperion gives us this figure of an ever
vigilant and observing watcher from
above the type of God that people who
aren't familiar with mythology would
associate the term God with but I'd like
to hear what you guys think were you
familiar with the role Hyperion played
in Greek mythology or when you think of
gods associated of the Sun and the skies
do you think of Apollo and Zeus instead
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained